[Musique]
la légion d'honneur créé par napoléon
bonaparte ya plus de 100 ans c'est la
décoration qui doit réconcilier les
français après les guerres civiles de la
révolution c'était la volonté de ne
faire qu'une seule nation et le sénat
très attaché à cette idée de nation à
cette idée de lady robe territoire en
forme une seule communauté nationale
ce c'était les membres qui a été créé un
siècle plus tard elle a pour but après
la grande guerre et tous les blessés
tous les morts et cdd particulièrement
les légionnaires qui avaient été décorés
ou les familles de légionnaires qui
avait disparu pas de médaille d'or
olympique trouve pas quelque chose qu'on
accroche c'est une reconnaissance de la
nation qui exige de s'engager auprès des
autres et chacun dans son coin conduit
des actions battent justement auprès des
anciens auprès des jeunes et chacun le
décline en fonction du tissu local n'est
pas la même chose dans le finistère donc
gers dans le bas-rhin etc c'est
l'occasion au travers de la société
d'entraidé des membres de la légion
d'honneur
d'exprimer le travail qui est fait sur
le terrain sur le territoire je vais
vous raconter l'histoire de la section
kate quand je suis mort dans
l'arrondissement de rambouillet
formidable travail auprès des jeunes de
pédagogie de citoyenneté fait avec les
enseignants donc une contribution à la
citoyenneté en même temps une action
d'entre elles et c'était pour moi
l'occasion de saluer ce que fait aussi
cette société d'entre elles
[Musique]